[Musique]
c'est comme qu'il faut
danser c'est comme qu'il faut danser
mange un
plumé comme dans le
menu plus relax plus en souplesse avec
à Max gentillesse
mais sans se laisser marcher Sur les
pieds c'est comme qu'il faut
danser c'est comme qu'il faut danser une
balle sois bondissant c'est pas le balle
t'est débutante ton papa t'attends pas la
sortie
la-bas le tcha cha cha donne chaud c'est
le tcha cha
[Musique]
chaud
faire 50 km Sud 1 m quel boulot
[Musique]
et aussi
c'est comme qu'il faut
[Musique]
danser c'est comme qu'il faut
danser que tu danses bien ou mal c'est
vraiment pas
capital le principal c'est que tu dans
que tu le moral et que sa
balance c'est pas la mort du signe le
Bol le tcha chaa donne chaud c'est le
tcha cha
[Musique]
cha
Oh